- Mein Name ist Osman Ocakdan.
Ich bin 23 Jahre alt und mach momentan
bei Edeka Engels meine Ausbildung
als Verkäufer.
- Ich bin Kim-Bastian Huberty
und bin seit Oktober
2013 Marktleiter.
- Ein guter Verkäufer muss
auf jeden Fall
sehr gut mit den Kunden
umgehen können,
sie beraten können
und ihnen auch dementsprechend
bei Problemen helfen können.
Das ist das Wichtigste hier im Laden.
- Er muss dem Kunden ja vermitteln,
dass er sich hier wohlfühlen kann
und dass er auch immer
wieder kommen kann.
- Im Einzelhandel geht es um Waren
und den Verkauf von verschiedenen
Produkten
wie zum Beispiel Obst,
Wurst,
Käse
und Getränken.
Verkäufer müssen die Waren,
die sie verkaufen, sehr gut kennen.
Auch die Warenkontrolle ist eine
wichtige Aufgabe des Verkäufers,
denn der Kunde will immer
frische Produkte kaufen.
Verkaufs- und Beratungsgespräche
mit Kunden sind wichtig,
auch das Bestellen von Waren,
die Warenannahme
und das Kassieren.
Mehr über den Beruf des Verkäufers
erfahrt ihr
im nächsten Teil.